hi guys Ned and Zack are gone they're
not dead they're just not here they're
with their families for the holiday
weekend
so you've seen tonight but hey we got
some days let's go to the Anime Expo and
just see what it's all about we have an
opportunity to explore all the great
boots and expositions cafe those yeah
everything revolve around Japanese
culture yeah I assume we're gonna try on
a bunch of different outfits just
overall have a Japanese time you're very
white today Keith I'm white every day
Yuji that's true the try guys try
cosplay episode 4 the try guys try
cosplay fashion so we are here at the H
Snell toll booth with Britni you're in a
trance today okay America do me John
Siever poncho to amaze yo yo new cool
fashion change their cognitive Emerson
can you make us into beautiful fashion
models with your line more better 16
Avengers
this will fit my body you're like a
little house on the Japanese prairie how
do you think he looks oh yeah definitely
sexy I love that you're constantly
raising your arms yeah because I'm
excited I'm gonna feel like an
old-fashioned baby
succeed peek sorry I'm baby XD Victoria
other son says you're a sexy Victorian
baby I've never had pants like this
close to my nipples oh my god I look
beautiful beautiful beautiful we got to
make you team look good somehow what
could you possibly dress him in that
will make him look even remotely
approachable it's happening
Eugene sticking is closed up nobody
faint
we tried I'm too bad looks like you're
not the sexiest baby I'm like the dark
sexy version of you yeah I say that's
true just without the clothes oh look at
the tiny hat it's like a lil yarmulke
yeah Judaism is huge in Japan
oh yeah we look like we're getting
married I'm a baby wife husband Oh baby
hey baby well you can't marry a baby if
you're not a baby
that's just not oh no I could still
marry a baby how do we look how does he
look so cool
I feel like I want like hot people
sexually I'd be like I'd be like
so there's my legs I must look like a
spider we're missing one thing right not
to son yeah please cut the rope too sexy
baby sexy baby so do you think we could
be your new models like next year yes
new thanks so much for letting us be
sexy ghosts ladies next time you go
shopping consider a tussle yes yes yes
awesome thank you we're here at the maid
and Butler booth cafe my name is Allie
and I am the anime expo maid and Butler
cafe manager arrives from Japan it plays
off the otaku fantasy it's this whole
role-playing thing so they welcome the
guests and they'd call the master or
mistress hello mistress hello mistress
so what else is entailed do I need to be
sexy no we're not touching so basically
just we needed dressed like maids and
look real quite and talk to strangers
give them a look to enemy Expo 2015
oh I know there's gonna be so freaking
cute look at these noise what is it with
Japan and dressing up like servants for
fun yes master
what game shall we play come over here
let me kiss that neck oh yeah why can't
I kiss their neck you need a maid named
neck kisser yeah - Keith - that sounds
like Pikachu Pikachu you've never made
out with anybody basically his name is
keep kiss alright so now it's time to
turn me into a butler yeah luckily today
I wore a full suit yeah against the
wishes of my entire production crew
hanky like then I use out whatever I
knew in the back of my heart
your heart says that I've somebody back
of your heart
we're a me I snow everything goes I
don't know what the heart is so
basically I just have to throw on this
vest and try so Eugene doesn't have to
get naked Friz I'm totally in character
genetically can I just be called like
Tokyo Drift the one thing about being a
butler that yet to remember is you're
yet to be a gentleman use the back of
your heart for that one mistress and now
we talk to people how are you yes what's
up you both look very beautiful as a
maid you should be serving the cookie
it's not eating the cookie I thought it
was a free cookie it's not a free cookie
I don't want to talk to you let's please
sit down oh my gosh this is so exciting
oh my god
welcome to our table mistresses yes
missus everyone gets some glass this is
my maid friend keep - and this is my
Butler friend
Tokyo Drift what fun we're having with
glass you guys also do sometimes a
little dance as well right do we put on
a really good show you can too
but fall in love
[Music]
so a lease on that was amazing thank you
I didn't know we're gonna get serenaded
yeah it's only happens over here at I
got danced upon yes he did and you did
not kiss anyone's neck I did steal a
cookie okay so for the butler and maid
cafe and with that our hero's adventures
in the world of cosplay have come to an
end having gained a respect and
understanding of the fandom the guys who
try will now focus their targets
elsewhere but the question still remains
what will they try now you've gotten me
again toast